Point Break the 2015 version is a remake
of the 1991 version starring Keanu
Reeves and Patrick Swayze directed by
Kathryn Bigelow in this film an
up-and-coming FBI agent befriends a guy
named Bodhi who's in a group that's
involved in quite a bit of robberies
that all involve some form of extreme
feats of insanity he goes undercover to
try to become friends with this group
now look in all honesty the original
Point Break isn't a great movie it's a
perfectly fun 90s action movie that
didn't need to be remade it's
unnecessary to remake this movie most
everyone really enjoys Point Break there
isn't a reason to remake Point Break
just like there isn't a reason to remake
memento but that's happening anyway
after watching the new film today I went
home and I rewatched the original just
to make sure that it was fresh in my
mind comparing this new film to the old
film there are a lot of differences
there's a ton actually one of the
biggest ones is that Johnny Utah isn't
Johnny Utah that's not actually his name
he just says that's a nickname and he
doesn't want to be called that rather
than a group committing robbery to fund
their endless summer and be surfers it's
a group trying to complete these eight
feats that are supposedly impossible all
around the world they're supposed to
make us fill one with the earth and
establish nirvana within ourselves but
the major difference and one of my
biggest issues with the character of
Johnny Utah even though it's not
actually his name is that he is an
extreme sports expert the film opens
with him on a motorbike going across
ramps on a mountaintop performing
death-defying stunts this is my biggest
issue with his character and the writing
for his character because it actually
really affects the movie especially as
an action movie as the film goes along
he's trying to get in with these people
doing all these crazy feats and he's
never afraid he never shows a sign of
fear he's never tensed because he's an
expert at these things he's perfect at
doing all of these in sane stunts that
basically require you to be Superman to
accomplish without dying so when our
hero feels no fear when he can do
everything like a superhero
we as an audience don't feel
vulnerability and we don't care when
these amazing sights are happening in
front of our eyes
and yes the stunts are very good if I
was grading this movie just purely on
the stunt team it would get an A+ they
did amazing work and it's impressive to
watch
although hyper actively edited it's not
shakey cam it's just there's way too
many cuts so why is that such a big
character issue for me well in the
original Point Break Keanu Reeves played
a new FBI agent who had to learn how to
surf he had to be taught how to surf by
this group he was taught by the girl
that he thought was hot and then Patrick
Swayze when they taught him successfully
how to surf and he felt that happening
within him he felt such elation he was
excited he felt something inside of him
change and he suddenly felt personal
about these people even though they were
criminals because they taught him
something and he discovered something
about himself in this film our main
characters already an expert at
everything so he's just there and he's
like yeah let's jump off this mountain
it'll be fun this film is just a series
of extreme sports related scenes all
strung together and in between these
scenes are your necessary exposition
scenes that let us know what's going on
in the plot world so since our main
character has no fear and is able to do
all these things perfectly there's no
sense of discovery there in the original
Point Break Keanu Reeves was like oh my
gosh I don't know what I'm feeling right
now I can't describe this feeling inside
me when he learns how to surf for the
first time and that gave him a
connection with these criminals and that
made the film interesting in this movie
there is no real connection between our
hero and the criminals he's just
pretending so there isn't much emotional
investment there because our hero isn't
really emotionally invested either guys
to sum this up really quickly the
original Point Break was a very fun 90s
action movie it was cheesy it was stupid
but it was really well directed by
Kathryn Bigelow who has proved herself
to be an excellent director this new
film is just an attempt to make an
extreme sports related action movie slap
the name Point Break on it thusly making
more money than you would have if you
would have just called it extreme ops -
which is what they should have called it
do you remember extreme ops man I saw
that movie in theaters home full that
was terrible and lastly it's pg-13 it's
all sanitized and clean there's nothing
about it that makes you recall the four
our joys of Point Break it's a dull sour
joyless film I'm gonna give Point Break
a d-plus I don't recommend seeing it the
same director made a film called
invincible with Mark Wahlberg very
underrated movie I do recommend seeing
that I don't know what happened with
this one guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes